Hollywood our welcome to blood-borne
Rhetta pharmacare we are in the town of
[ __ ] hell
[ __ ] hello how's everyone doing
remember there was this Cthulhu get that
[ __ ] up there keep shooting me Oh God
that is the nastiest [ __ ] pain oh my
god I need to look closer better oh that
is so they look like tiny zits that I
just want to pop I'm gonna pop them and
cry listen to like sad music that's what
I want to do I hate you you're so nasty
why do they have to be hairy they look
like someone's balls that look like a
ball sack that someone try to keep alive
for millions of years now there's some
some [ __ ] in here we go and
take them out one by one cuz they don't
respawn I'm sorry I played like five
minutes last night alright don't cry we
gotta walk slow so they don't they don't
know that we eating a bro oh god oh god
he saw me he has my same outfit it's
like damn oh god what the oh god there's
two of them there's two there's dose of
the pretty puss i'ma get gear I'm gonna
empty skin da yeah oh they don't give up
do they what the [ __ ] who shot you stop
stop job job job
[ __ ] like your coat is it Gucci no
big deal oh [ __ ] far no big deal
[ __ ] no big deal oh my god he's so
strong all right buzz let's do while we
were supposed to do before I became a
shoe that Ryan holy [ __ ] key a food hey
fool hey there buddy
[ __ ] I wanted to fist him here have a
knife here have another knife you want
another knife you want another name oh
god no what the [ __ ] did you come from I
don't have time for this
jahmai the day isn't wet so what you
want points on I got I got what's up
with Jason oh [ __ ]
that's a great move there son whoa there
we go all right one down yes oh you so
dead [ __ ] oh you so dead [ __ ] take
this no no no aah no no no no no hey no
I don't wanna die no hey no 20 minutes
nothing
Pokemon Pokemon
how is he not dead yet oh oh oh
Lamaze oh that was way harder than the
first one
oh this place is lovely more great just
look at the architecture oh it's a bell
[ __ ]
never mind Margaret they have bell
[ __ ] oh that dome surprise
[ __ ] oh my god did not ask for
this nope nope nope nope [ __ ] that I did
not walk in that casually
oh look bill ladies I love them you and
your little pal
oh look oh god there's an army of Bell
ladies this is my nightmare okay I don't
care okay I do care what the [ __ ] is
that a galaxy a slime galaxy cool okay
just hanging around
yeah everyone Oh God oh it gets better
nice oh hey there buddy
you are one slimy little beast aren't ya
all right then I'm gonna go and cry now
the one reborn what a fantastic name I
hear bail ladies how do we get to excuse
me
my mommy yeah here we go again mama ah
nervous this eye look guess you ain't no
bail anymore Pete Oh God well that was
fun let's never do that again [ __ ] hey
that's a nice bed where'd you get it
huh wait one more bail [ __ ] and then
we're out of here goodbye all right now
we can find cello how are you Oh God
[ __ ] hey he [ __ ] kicked me
stop kicking me what's happening
Oh
of course of course of course
all the single Bailey's all the single
bellies all the single bellies all just
think about it
what what happens come on just on insta
come ah so [ __ ] confused there's so
many limbs half health baby Oh God
[ __ ] you brain [ __ ] on me
I love [ __ ] but that's not a good [ __ ]
yes
[ __ ] destroying this [ __ ] oh oh
internal [ __ ] take all my Charmander
they're free this is not happening what
happened what does that mean did I do it
did I do what you did I not do it I
don't understand please please please oh
they're so soft yep
[ __ ] day oh thank you Jesus if you
hear me my god [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and we lit the candle we will keep going
res that's what we're doing we're here
to finish this [ __ ] hey are you doing
yeah like your head where did you get it
hello mom
are you okay there mommy I'm scared mom
nice oh my god oh my [ __ ] god
what are you I like your head begone
spawn of Sato
don't pour water at me that's super rude
super rude it's dead so rude it's
they're rude get it oh well wrong door
goddamn it oh this place is lovely
Margaret look what lovely little stone
creations Margaret Margaret the bell
ringing woman's rings the Sinister bell
you know what I'm really [ __ ] tired
of the bell ringing [ __ ] sinister
Bell resonates with another okay Oh
somebody's invading me oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I
wish I had my cannon a [ __ ] joke I
can't return oh this is so [ __ ] all
right fight me you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh come on you're gonna heal what a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
come on healing you [ __ ] [ __ ] heal
oh you [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
come on oh that's funny thanks for the
soul [ __ ]
I have a bad feeling about this fear
footing okay Yolo Yolo indeed don't
throw stones at me mate don't threw
stones at me me wow wow wow wow don't
through soon oh god that's a big that's
a big a stone you get a mate well it do
me a favor and don't throw a stone you
threw a stone anyway migrate say you
married me to you number three where is
she don't think I don't see you my right
number oh my where I don't see you damn
it this is the problem there you are
you [ __ ] ass beat her what is this plus
it's so strange
Oh God is that a shortcut interesting
alright yay
oh god this looks like a boss please
don't be a boss no no oh god no what do
you do then
[ __ ] deaf lasers cool and hit your
leg oh I do so much damage on her that's
great
[ __ ] sake don't stomp you little
[ __ ] or [ __ ] face planned me you
come what a [ __ ] [ __ ] what's with my
damage I'm trying to hit her tail yeah
tail is a weak spot what the [ __ ] Oh
give it to me
give me your [ __ ] arm you [ __ ] put
it down put down your [ __ ] Oh mate
yes oh god what is that
I'm saying what is that she man now
oh she mad [ __ ] man
Oh God [ __ ] is angry
[ __ ] sake let me heal or not see if I
care
it's gonna be neither one is great
oh she's waiting for me that's Sookie oi
I love you
you think oh my god
best boss fight ever
that's pretty good some people are
saying this is the hardest boss in the
game we'll see about that
[ __ ] your arms up [ __ ] calm down baby
it's gonna be okay baby I hit your hand
baby let me hold your hand ah you do
that thing it hurts out oh you're doing
that thing where it hurts
you're hurting me don't hurt me don't
don't hurt me okay I'm gonna okay yeah
let me hold yo hane [ __ ] ah and I'm
dead [ __ ] you then Oh Mon the ass will
be sucked tonight
I don't think she likes it got this
crazy feeling she's not into me I want
to shoot that [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
can I take screenshot here well I didn't
want to all right then it looks like we
left in that episode there wasn't that
amazing go ahead and hit punch that like
button like a boss you want the next
part and when maybe will destroy our
nightmares stay awesome
oh my god I'm a [ __ ] boss mushroom